En algunas partes del mundo,
la situación también se ha transformado en un estremecedor problema social.
En Asia, por ejemplo,
los medios informaron que algunos pacientes, en su desesperación,
consiguen órganos en el cruel mercado negro.
Sin duda, urge encontrar una solución a este acuciante problema.
Hay vidas humanas en juego.
Como bióloga y genetista,
mi misión es colaborar para resolver este problema.
Hoy digo con optimismo que estamos en el camino correcto,
gracias a Laika.
Mediante la tecnología para modificar genes,
actualmente existe la maravillosa posibilidad de crear un órgano
apto para ser trasplantado en humanos
a partir de la cría de cerdos y de manera segura.
Antes de referirme a la increíble ciencia que lo hace posible,
tratemos de entender primero qué es el "xenotrasplante".
Es el proceso de trasplantar órganos de animales en humanos.
Se preguntarán, ¿por qué órganos de cerdo?
Porque los órganos de estos animales tienen un tamaño y una fisiología
similar al de los órganos humanos.
En el último medio siglo,
los pioneros en trasplantes hicieron todo lo posible por lograrlo,
pero con éxito limitado o nulo.
¿Por qué?
Dos obstáculos principales se presentaron en el camino.
Primero surgió el problema del rechazo.
Cuando nuestro sistema inmunitario detecta que el nuevo órgano es extraño,
lo rechaza.
Segundo, y esto es específico de los órganos porcinos,
los cerdos son portadores de un virus que es benigno para el animal
pero puede ser transmitido a los humanos.
Se denomina "retrovirus endógeno porcino", o PERV,
y tiene el potencial de causar una epidemia viral similar a la del VIH.
Como no se podía resolver el problema de manera eficiente,
la investigación del xenotrasplante estuvo estancada durante más de una década.
Es poco el progreso logrado, hasta ahora.
Les contarés ahora cómo llegué hoy hasta aquí con Laika.
Mi viaje comenzó en el monte Emei, China.
Este lugar está muy bien descrito en varias historias legendarias,
como "El tigre y el dragón".
Este es mi lugar en el mundo.
Al criarme en la montaña,
mi conexión con la naturaleza siempre fue muy fuerte.
Esta soy yo a los siete años
parada frente a un antiguo templo budista
con un mono en el hombro.
Aún recuerdo claramente cuando con mis amigos
esparcíamos maníes por todos lados para distraer a los monos
y así poder cruzar y hacer caminatas por el valle.
Amo la naturaleza.
Cuando llegó el momento de elegir una carrera,
decidí estudiar biología en la Universidad de Pekín, en Beijing.
Pero cuanto más aprendía,
más cosas me cuestionaba.
¿Cómo era posible que nuestra estructura genética sea tan parecida a los animales
y nuestra apariencia sea tan diferente?
¿Cómo hace nuestro sistema inmunitario para defenderse de tantos patógenos
y a la vez tener la habilidad de no atacarnos a nosotros mismos?
Este tipo de preguntas me atormentaban.
Sé que es un poco 'nerd', pero recuerden que soy científica.
Cuando terminé la universidad, no quise limitarme a tan solo hacer preguntas.
Quería responderlas, y así lo hice.
En 2008, tuve la suerte de ser aceptada
en un programa de doctorado en la Universidad de Harvard
y allí trabajé con el Dr. George Church.
En el laboratorio del Dr. Church, empecé a estudiar y experimentar
con la estructura genética de los mamíferos.
De esos experimentos,
hubo uno en particular que me acercó a Laika.
En 2013, con mi equipo de trabajo hicimos alteraciones en una célula humana
con una herramienta que quizá conozcan
llamada "CRISPR".
Fuimos uno de los dos primeros grupos
en usar con éxito esa herramienta para cambiar nuestro ADN.
Fue un momento inolvidable en el descubrimiento científico.
La herramienta CRISPR para editar genes se compone de dos elementos.
Por un lado, unas tijeras llamadas "enzima CRISPR"
y por el otro, lo que se llama un "ARN guía".
Imagínenlo como tijeras genéticas con un microscopio.
El microscopio es un ARN guía
que coloca las tijeras en el sitio que deseamos cortar
y dice, "Aquí está",
y la enzima CRISPR corta y repara el ADN como queremos.
A poco de dar a conocer este estudio,
los médicos del Mass General Hospital quisieron conocer las aplicaciones médicas
de nuestra investigación.
Nos contactaron
y juntos empezamos a ver el potencial de CRISPR
para resolver la crisis de la escasez de órganos.
¿Cómo lo hicimos?
Es sencillo, pero a la vez complejo.
Hicimos cambios en una célula de cerdo para que esté libre de virus
y sea compatible con el sistema inmunológico humano.
El núcleo de esa célula se implanta luego en el óvulo de una cerda
que luego se divide para formar el embrión.
Ese embrión se coloca en el útero de una madre sustituta
y se divide para formar un cerdo.
Básicamente, es un proceso de clonación.
Los órganos del cerdo recién nacido tienen una carga genética
que no sería rechazada por el sistema inmunitario del ser humano.
En 2015, nuestro equipo decidió resolver antes el problema de la transmisión viral.
Nuestra idea era extraer las 62 copias del virus PERV
del genoma del cerdo,
pero en esa época era casi una misión imposible.
Aun usando el CRISPR,
podíamos hacer tan solo una o dos modificaciones dentro de la célula.
El máximo de modificaciones que hicimos en una célula fue cinco.
Para lograrlo, era necesario multiplicar esa cantidad por diez.
Usando un diseño muy controlado y cientos de ensayos,
logramos extraer todos los virus,
y superamos el máximo.
Fundamentalmente, nuestros estudios demostraron
que podíamos desactivar la posibilidad de que este peligroso virus
se transmita a los humanos.
El año pasado, con una célula modificada y con tecnología de clonación,
nuestra 'startup', llamada eGenesis, produjo a Laika,
la primera cerda en su tipo nacida libre de PERV.
(Aplausos)
Laika representa el primer paso fundamental
para hacer un xenotrasplante seguro.
También es una plataforma
para poder hacer otras modificaciones genéticas
y resolver el problema inmunológico.
Desde entonces, creamos más de 30 cerdos libres de PERV,
y puede que sean los animales genéticamente modificados
más avanzados del mundo.
La bautizamos Laika por la perra soviética,
el primer animal en orbitar la Tierra.
Esperamos que Laika y sus hermanos
nos conduzcan a nuevas fronteras de la ciencia y la medicina.
Imaginemos un mundo donde los pacientes con insuficiencia hepática
puedan salvar su vida con un nuevo hígado
sin tener que esperar una donación
o la muerte de otra persona.
Imaginemos un mundo donde las personas que padecen de diabetes
no tengan que depender de la insulina luego de cada comida
porque pueden recibir células pancreáticas sanas
que producen insulina por sí solas.
Imaginemos un mundo donde los pacientes con insuficiencia renal
no tengan que someterse a la tan incómoda diálisis.
Estamos haciendo lo posible por crear un mundo así,
un mundo sin escasez de órganos.
Por fin contamos con la herramienta para abordar un problema
que antes nunca pudimos solucionar,
y Laika es tan solo el comienzo de nuestro viaje.
Debemos adoptar una postura humilde frente a la naturaleza,
porque hay otros problemas por resolver,
como la inmunología
y demás cosas que hoy ni imaginamos.
Pero tenemos la responsabilidad de aplicar la ciencia de avanzada
en la medicina para salvar la vida de los pacientes en lista de espera.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)
Chris Anderson: Luhan, un trabajo extraordinario.
Adelántate, por favor.
¿Cuál es el siguiente paso? Ya eliminaron el virus.
El próximo paso será llegar al punto
en que el cuerpo humano no rechace un trasplante.
¿Qué implica esto?
Luhan Yang: Es un proceso muy complejo.
Hay que extraer el antígeno de los cerdos.
Además, podemos aprender mucho del cáncer,
cómo el cáncer puede invadir o eludir nuestro sistema inmunológico
y usar ese artilugio del cáncer
e implementarlo en el órgano del cerdo
para burlar nuestro sistema inmunitario y que de este modo no ataque al órgano.
CA: ¿Cuándo crees o esperas
que se harán los primeros trasplantes exitosos?
LY: Sería irresponsable de mi parte si te diera algún plazo.
CA: Estamos en TED, siempre somos irresponsables.
LY: Pero estamos trabajando día y noche
para poder lograrlo en beneficio de los pacientes.
CA: Pero ¿dirías que podría ocurrir
en el término de una década o de unos cinco años?
LY: Sin duda, creemos que será posible dentro de la década.
(Risas)
CA: Muchos de los que están aquí deben estar muy esperanzados
porque el potencial es extraordinario.
Pero puede haber otros que piensen,
"Es una cerda muy simpática.
Los humanos no deberíamos explotar animales tan bonitos
para nuestro beneficio".
¿Tienes respuesta a eso?
LY: Por supuesto.
Imaginemos que un cerdo puede salvar la vida de ocho personas.
Además, al igual que la donación humana,
si solo extraemos un riñón de un cerdo,
el animal puede seguir viviendo,
es decir que somos muy conscientes al respecto,
pero nuestro objetivo es tan solo suplir la necesidad médica insatisfecha
para esos pacientes y sus familias.
CA: Por otro lado, nadie puede objetar nada si come tocino, ¿verdad?
LY: Claro, tienes razón.
(Risas)
CA: Luhan, muchas gracias. LY: Gracias a ti.
(Aplausos)